[Music]
all the world's a stage from as you like
it by William Shakespeare all the
world's a stage and all the men and
women merely players they have their
exits and their entrances and one man in
his time plays many parts his acts being
seven ages at first the infant mewling
and puking in the nurses arms and then
the whining schoolboy with his satchel
and shining morning face creeping like
snail unwillingly to school and then the
lover sighing like furnace with a woeful
ballad made to his mistress eyebrow
then a soldier full of strange oaths and
bearded like the pard jealous in honor
sudden and quick in quarrel seeking the
bubble reputation even in the cannons
now
and then the justice in fair round belly
with good Capon lined with eyes severe
and beard of formal cut full of wise
saws and modern instances and so he
plays his part the sixth age shifts into
the lean and slippered Pantaloon with
spectacles on nose and pouch on side his
youthful hose well saved a world too
wide for his shrunk shank and his big
manly voice turning again toward
childish treble pipes and whistles in
his sound last scene of all that ends
this strange eventful history is second
childishness and mere oblivion sans
teeth sans eyes sans taste sounds
everything for an analysis of the poem
watch this video or check out the next
poem in this series